I want to be in the Leslie Odom junior
shot to fame in the hit musical Hamilton
you won a Tony Award and Grammy Award
for playing the original Aaron Burr was
also appeared on screen in smash and the
House of Lies and in the movie Murder on
the Orient Express been very busy
Odom's new book is failing up how to
take risk aim higher and never stop
learning
he shares personal stories and life
lessons to help you follow your dreams
he writes this the past two moments of
greatness in your life will be paved in
part with your spectacular failures
Leslie Odom jr. we welcome you back to
the table thank you so much failure
isn't something most people want to talk
about or even think about and we
certainly dread it we don't want it to
happen but you write in your book
everything changed when you gave
yourself permission to fail sounds like
you're encouraging failure yeah I mean I
feel like so much of my adulthood has
been about holding two truths at the
same time and being really comfortable
with that so there's a there's a whole
lot of focus on the tremendous success
that that me and my my cast mates have
had because of the you know the embrace
of the show but the truth is there's a
whole lot of roots under that tree sure
and there's a whole lot of hard work and
failure along the way so I wanted to
point to that because that's what got us
there your best lesson you've learned
from failure as well that are the best
lesson that I learned from failure is
that you know that's really where the
learning happens jay-z has this quote
you know that he's he's found it really
hard to learn from success yeah learn
from the failure it's a conversation you
end up having with your kids it's like
it's not if you fall down it's it's it's
the getting up absolutely you know it's
the getting up you you a lot of people
say that that one teacher can change a
kid's life and in your case it was a
fifth grade social studies teacher yeah
I you know I feel like this is Turner
mrs. Turner
Francis Turner she changed my life and
the thing about the thing about a great
teacher a great mentor you know I bet a
lot of you know you guys feel the same
way it's like they can you can be
radicalized by a great teacher you know
they can turn you into a teacher they
turn you into a mentor because you you
want to pass on those lessons that they
gave you and you want to you were a
troublemaker huh I was I was a handful
mrs. Turner believe me what was the best
lesson she gave you well she kind of
reframed my idea of who I was you know
mrs. Turner was the first one that
encouraged me to write in in a way
dedicate this book to her to all my
teachers because there was a there was a
mentorship and and a sewing that I was
doing in the community you know in with
college kids and high school kids and
stuff that bet she got started you know
for me yeah you write that it took you a
year to get over Hamilton did you have
Hamilton withdrawal is that what we
could call it it's it was like a
Hamilton hangover for sure you know
because that was a trip you know it was
like um you know we went in one way and
you come out on the other side and
people know your name and they're
stopping you in the airport and stuff
let's say I got goose bumps so listening
to your voice again every time I hear
the music it gives me a thing and you
said you knew within eight seconds and
20 bars it was gonna be hit what is it
eight seconds and 20 bars you heard how
does a bastard or son of a [ __ ] and a
Scotsman jaw I mean it was just it was
so fresh and confident and brilliant you
know I mean those four I said you know
like so many people if if I hate the
rest of this show that opens it alone no
but he but he does sustain that
excellence for three hours it's
extraordinary but you almost quit
yeah acting you almost walked away but
it was it was it was a mentor and
eventually your father like that who
said to you I want to see you try first
once you try before you quit you're
thinking haven't I been trying right
yeah but he said he said to me now I was
sitting on my couch I was you know
very depressed and sad you know about
the way things were going the roller
coaster that up and down and he said to
me so I Wendy when he said you know I
want to see you try first before you
quit I said what do you think I've been
doing he said well when the phone rings
I think you show up and you're prepared
and you do a great job you're affable
guy and great the phone didn't ring
today what did you do for yourself did
you read anything did you write anything
did you call anyone did you send an
email you can just go you know it he
pointed to you know half of my business
if not more you know as a freelance
artist as a freelance business person
you know that I was ignoring and it
changed my life got me off my couch one
of the lessons you share is from
rehearsing for the Broadway run of
Hamilton you write quote you have to be
both a harsh critic and strong advocate
for yourself yeah that's a hard one to
balance yeah you can't yes you need both
things though it's all about balance you
you have to you can't sit around reading
your press clippings all day no matter
how you know good or you know
yesterday's news yeah you know you have
to you have to believe in yourself and
you have to also look at the things you
need to change and change it you also
write when you're waiting for the Tony
nominations you and your wife Nicolette
went out to breakfast you ordered
waffles and pancakes at a diner your
favorite diner what is the name of that
diner come towards yours I want to go
there 53rd and 9th the way you wrote
about the big waffles I'm thinking yeah
we said if we if we you know after these
pancakes if they're no Tony nominations
we will still be all right going yeah
well let the aggressor what a pleasure
to have you here grats on the book and
failing up is on sale now